Das ist ein bisschen gelb.
Ja.
Ja, okay.
Ja, ich bräuchte ein paar Sekunden.
Und meine Landesbogenpause bereiten darf ich vorbereiten?
Aber natürlich.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Aber Herr Doktor beeilen sich bitte.
Ich habe Schmerzen. Ich bin extra gekommen.
Ja, okay.
Da haut es lang. Soll ich woanders hingehen?
Ja, ja. Entschuldigen Sie.
Ich möchte Ihnen jetzt dokumentieren, was Sie erwähnen.
So, ich entschuldige mich für die Verspätung.
Ja, guten Tag.
Guten Abend.
Mein Name ist Martin.
Und heute bin ich der Dienstherbender auf dieser Station.
Ich möchte Ihnen gerne das Herzgespräch führen.
Herzlichen Dank.
Ja, natürlich.
Ich bin extra in dieses Krankenhaus gekommen,
weil es ein gutes Krankenhaus ist.
Ja, Sie haben eine gute Entscheidung getroffen.
Ja, das werden wir sehen.
Ja, vielen Dank.
Ja, ich werde so erst ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen.
Dann kommen wir auch sofort zu Ihrem Beschweden.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Martin Zawa.
Martin Zawa.
Herr Zawa, könnten Sie bitte Ihren Nachnamen
ustabilen?
Zawa wie Zawa, Sie, Kritt Anton?
Ja.
Oder Emil Richard?
Ja, vielen Dank.
Herr Zawa, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 39 Jahre alt.
39 Jahre alt.
Wie groß sind Sie?
1,73 m.
Wie sind Sie?
Ungefähr 85 kg.
85 kg.
Vielen Dank für die Informationen.
Herr Zawa, was für Sie heute uns?
Herr Doktor, ich habe jetzt Entschuldigung Ihren Namen vergessen.
Wie ist Ihren Namen nochmal, bitte?
Ja, mein Name ist Ergigid.
Ergigid, interessante Name.
Woher kommt der Name?
Ist aber nicht Deutsch, oder?
Ja, ich komme aus der Türkei.
Sehr schön.
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen so komische Bauchschmerzen.
Das wird immer schlimmer.
Und so dass jetzt auch die Medikamente,
die ich genommen habe, nicht helfen.
Es sind so krampfartige Schmerzen.
Herr Zawa, könnten Sie mir sagen, wo genau die Schmerzen sind?
Also hier im Oberbauch.
Das strahlt so ein bisschen wie ein Gürtel aus.
Okay, Oberbauch.
Das geht auch manchmal so ein bisschen in den Rücken.
Oberbauch.
Mit Strahlen.
Rücken.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Könnten Sie die Schmerzen genau beschreiben?
Eher drückend.
Ja, das ist so ein bisschen krampfartig.
Manchmal bekomme ich Krämpfe.
Ja, und dann habe ich auch so einen Druck.
Und es ist sehr, sehr unangenehm.
Ich habe dann Blähungen, wenn mein Bauch bläht auf.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Zawa, wie schnell sind die Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala von Eisbesieden?
Heute sind sie sehr stark.
Deswegen bin ich auch gekommen.
Ich dachte, das geht vorbei.
Aber ich würde sagen jetzt bei 7, 8,
nach dieser Skala fragen.
Ja, kürzlich.
Ich werde die Schmerzen bis Ende des Gesprächs aufhalten.
Also, wäre ich, also wenn Sie etwas gegen die Schmerzen geben,
wäre ich Ihnen sehr dankbar.
Ich habe schon zu Hause 2 Ibuprofen genommen.
Und nochmal eine Paracetamol.
Aber es hat nicht viel geholfen.
Kennen Sie die Dosier von Ibuprofen?
Ich glaube, das waren 400 Milligramm, glaube ich.
400 Milligramm und Paracetamol?
Oh, das weiß ich nicht.
Die haben mir, glaube ich, nur eine Dose.
Ich glaube, das waren 500 Milligramm.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ja, Herr Zawa, ich erfülle Ihnen,
Schmerzmittel am Ende des Gesprächs.
Wenn Sie das Wort haben, dann muss ich eine genaue Diagnose bestätigen.
Ja, wenn es lange dauert, dann würde ich schon sagen,
lieber jetzt, aber wenn das Gespräch nicht so lange dauert,
dann halte ich es vielleicht noch aus, aber es sind schon starke Schmerzen,
Herr Doktor.
Ja, es dauert ca. 20 Minuten.
Oh, nein, nein, das ist viel zu lange, Herr Doktor.
Dann will ich jetzt meine Schmerzmittel, bitte, sofort.
Okay, okay, Herr Zawa, ich werde Sie schnell wie möglich untersuchen
und dann werde ich Ihnen Schmerzmittel verbrauchen.
Ja, bitte, also 20 Minuten will ich nicht warten.
Ich habe schon seit zwei Tagen starke Schmerzen, bitte.
Okay, Herr Zawa, ja, ich werde um Ihre Beschwerden kümmern.
Ja, Sie haben gesagt, dass die seit zwei Tagen
Oberbauchschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung im Rücken.
Und Sie sind du, Kinder, und Sie haben zweimal Buprofen
und einmal Palästermol eingemacht.
Genau.
Und diese Enkamente haben Ihnen...
Haben nicht geholfen, nur ganz kurz.
Ja, okay, okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie bemerkt, dass...
Haben Sie etwas bemerkt, dass die Schmerzzylinder oder versteckt?
Kann ich nicht sagen, also, die sind von alleine schlimmer geworden.
Ich habe jetzt kaum was gegessen.
Seit gestern, ich habe mich nicht getraut,
aber das ist halt gestern zunehmend.
Also, ich finde jetzt keinen Auslöser.
Okay, kein Auslöser und...
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sind diese Schmerzen dauerhaft oder...
Es kommt und geht, aber in den letzten Zeitheutemittag ist es anhaltend.
Ich konnte nicht ganz verstehen.
Seit heute Mittag ist es anhaltend, also dauerhaft.
Okay, dauerhaft, dauerhaft, vielen Dank.
Herr Zauer, bis auf oberengenannte Beschwerden
haben Sie noch etwas umgewöhnliches bemerkt?
Kann ich jetzt nicht sagen, also, das sind komische Schmerzen.
Ich glaube, mein Stuhlgang ist auch ganz komisch geworden seit zwei Tagen.
Das hat eine komische Form.
Die Farbe hat sich geändert.
Es ist ein bisschen hell.
Also, das macht mir auch so ein bisschen Sorgen und Gedanken.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen?
Wie ich gesagt habe, haben Sie eine gute Entscheidung getroffen?
Ja, das will ich doch hoffentlich machen.
Ich mache mir natürlich schon Sorgen.
Das ist doch ein schlimmes, das ist etwas bösartiges.
Woher kommt das so plötzlich? Das habe ich noch nie gehabt.
Ja, jetzt kann ich nicht genau sagen,
aber nach einigen Maßnahmen können wir genau beschreiben.
Ja, ich hoffe, ich hoffe.
Ja, jetzt würde ich unser Gespräch fortsetzen, okay?
Ja bitte, unbedingt.
Okay, haben Sie Probleme beim Wasserlassen?
Nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Können Sie sich füllen?
Ich habe jetzt kein Fieber gemessen,
aber Fieber habe ich glaube ich nicht.
Okay.
Leiden Sie unter Nachtschweiß oder Stelfrost?
Nein, eigentlich schlafe ich normalerweise guter.
Aber heute Nachtwasser gegen den Schmerzen.
Etwas anstrengend.
Okay.
Ist Ihnen üben?
Ja, das ist heute Morgen.
Gestern war es noch nicht, aber seit heute Morgen.
Seit heute Morgen.
Okay, dann haben Sie Elbruchen?
Ja, aber nur ganz wenig.
Einmal so ein galliges Sekret kam raus,
aber weil ich auch wahrscheinlich nichts gegessen hatte.
Einmal haben Sie Elbruchen?
Ja, ganz wenig.
Was haben Sie Elbruchen?
Ein galliges Sekret.
Ein bisschen grünlich, sauer.
Okay.
Herr Sauer, haben Sie Probleme beim Einschlafen oder durchschlafen?
Wie gesagt, nein, bisher hatte ich nicht.
Jetzt nur mit den Schmerzen, es ist etwas schwierig natürlich,
aber sonst habe ich keine Schlachtprobleme.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Haben Sie in den nächsten sechs Monaten ungewollt ab oder zu genommen?
Nein.
Okay.
Hatten Sie früher eine Bechwerden?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal. Ich kenne das gar nicht.
Das ist ganz schlimm.
Ich hatte ja schon mal eine Gastritismal gehabt,
aber solche Schmerzen hatte ich noch nie.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Sauer, ich werde mich bald um Ihre Bechwerden kümmern,
aber nun hätte ich noch einige Fragen zu Ihrem Vorgeschwistern.
Ja, bitte.
Sie stellen mir nur Fragen. Sie wollten mich untersuchen.
Sie wollten Blut abnehmen. Sie wollten mir Schmerzmedikamente geben.
Wie lange wollen Sie sich noch unterhalten?
Ja, Herr Sauer, wie ich gesagt habe,
möchte ich Ihnen schnell wie möglich...
Ja, ja, bitte, bitte.
Ich glaube, jetzt ist eine Zeit,
dass ich etwas gegen die Schmerzen bekomme.
Ja, aber jetzt brauche ich diese Informationen,
um eine genaue Diagnostomestätik festzustellen.
Aber das können Sie immer noch machen, Herr Doktor.
Ich habe Schmerzen. Ich bitte Sie.
Ja, okay. Herr Sauer, leiden Sie an Irgendwelche Erkrankungen?
Ich meine Bluthochdruck oder Suckerkrankheit?
Nein, nein.
Okay.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert?
Ja, als Kind ist der blind am operiert worden.
Wie alt waren Sie als Kind?
Ich war acht Jahre alt.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Ansonsten wurden Sie operiert?
Nein, ich war ansoßen kerngesund.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Außer diese EU-Profen und Parastomol
nehmen Sie irgendeine Präfikmedikamente
bei Bedarf oder Regeln?
Nein, eigentlich habe ich keine Medikamente.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sieht bei Ihnen Allergien oder Unverzweckten bekannt?
An sich nicht. Ich habe gegen ein, zwei Polen Allergien,
aber diese Immunose ist sehr kurz und das ist an sich nichts Schlimmes.
Okay, wie reagieren Sie darauf?
Ja, mit meiner Nase läuft, meine Augen drehen ein bisschen.
Aber merke ich es nicht.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Sind Sie vorgelegt?
Bitte, was bin ich?
Ich gehe immer davon aus, mein Haushalt hat es überwacht
und du meintest, es sind im Moment keine Impfungen nötig.
Also ich gehe schon mal davon aus, ja.
Ja, auch so.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Sauer, warum Sie?
Ich habe bis vor vier Jahren geraucht, aber seit vier Jahren nicht mehr.
Seit vier Jahren.
Wie viel haben Sie vor geraucht?
Das war so eine Schachtel pro Tag.
Wie lange haben Sie geraucht?
Bitte.
Auch gut, über 20 Jahre.
Best 20 Jahre, okay.
Nehmen Sie Alkohol zu sich?
An sich, das passt gar nicht, nur auf einer Feier oder so.
Normalerweise trinke ich keine Alkohol.
Haben Sie Erfahrung mit Drogen?
Erfahrung, mein Kind, das hört es, aber ich selbst habe
jetzt keine probiert, wenn Sie das mal haben.
Ja, okay, vielen Dank.
Tragen Sie Sport?
Manchmal.
Was tragen Sie?
Bitte, Entschuldigung.
Wenn der Alkohol zu sein ist.
Ich habe es akustisch nicht gehört.
Sie haben manchmal gesagt, was schreiben Sie?
Ich meine, Biscuit, Wander?
Ach so, ich fahre Fahrrad.
Vielen Dank.
Herr Sauer, sind Sie in den letzten 6 Monaten gereist?
Ich meine Ausland oder in Land?
Nein, nein.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Sauer, jetzt hätte ich einige Fragen zu Ihrer
Familienvorgeschichte.
Sind Ihre Eltern noch am Leben?
Ja, die leben noch.
Sind Sie gesund?
Also mein Vater hat ein Diabetes, der nimmt, glaube ich, Tabletten.
Und hohen Blutdruck, aber mehr weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Und meine Mutter ist eigentlich gesund.
Also, sie ist sehr lebt gesund, achtet auf Ihre Ernährung.
Sobald ich weiß, hat sie keine Probleme.
Okay, gesund.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe nur eine Schwester, ja.
Ist sie gesund?
Ja, sie ist weniger als ich und hat auch soweit ich weiß, kein Problem.
Okay, vielen Dank.
Herr Sauer, sind Sie berühstetig?
Ja, ich arbeite auf der Baustelle, ich bin Bauingenieur.
Bauingenieur, okay, vielen Dank.
Wie ist Ihre Familie starten?
Also ich hatte eine Freundin,
wir haben uns vor einer Woche getrennt.
Als im Moment bin ich alleine.
Okay, so jetzt wohnen Sie alleine?
Ich bin im Moment alleine, ja.
Ist auch gut so, wenn ich im Moment keine Partnerschaft.
Ja, manchmal ist es gut.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Okay, vielen Dank.
Was meinst du, Doktor, was ist das jetzt?
Wollen Sie mir den Schmerzmedikament geben?
Ja, Herr Sauer, meine Sorge habe ich alle wichtige
Informationen gesammelt,
aber alle Massnahmen sind wichtig für uns.
Zuerst würde ich sie korpellig untersuchen,
dann die Massnahmen entlassen.
Nach diesem Massnahmen kann ich Ihnen genau beschreiben,
aber natürlich habe ich jetzt...
Aber bitte geben Sie mir erstmal jetzt den Schmerzmedikament,
bevor Sie anfangen zu untersuchen, die Schläge.
Sollte Sie sagen, dass der Schmerzmedikament nicht kommt?
Ich glaube, ich muss bei Andersing gehen.
Ja Herr Sauer, ich verstehe Sie,
aber wenn ich Ihnen Medikamente gebe,
kann das meine Schmerzmedikamente nicht gehen.
Ich habe meine Diagnose...
meine Diagnose...
Ja, wir einfließen.
Ich bitte Ihnen ein bisschen zu warten.
Doktor, ich warte jetzt schon eine halbe Stunde.
Ich bitte Sie, ich habe seit zwei Tagen Schmerzen,
die Sie nicht noch länger warten.
Sie haben einen Recht,
Sie können trotzdem untersuchen.
Geben Sie jetzt etwas gegen die Schmerzen oder nicht?
Ja, natürlich.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe, nach dem Untersuchungen...
Das wollten Sie vor eine halbe Stunde machen.
Sie stellen mir immer eine Frage,
aber meine Schmerzen nehmen Sie nicht ernst.
Ich glaube, ich muss zu Ihrem Chef gehen.
Das reicht jetzt.
Ja, natürlich nehme ich Sie ernst.
Aber wie ich gesagt habe,
zuerst würde ich Ihnen eine Körperdrehuntersuchung...
Ich bestehe darauf, dass jetzt erst etwas gegen die Schmerzen bekommen.
Ich habe starke Schmerzen.
Dann können Sie mich untersuchen.
Dann können Sie auch von mir machen, was Sie wollen.
Ja, okay.
Ich schlage Ihnen vor,
dass wir eine Massname zum Beispiel Bauchultraschein
oder Computer-Tomographie durchführen.
Dann kann ich Ihnen diese Schmerzmittel verordnen.
Nein, ich gehe zwar anders hin.
Geben Sie mir Ihren Namen, ich will jetzt Ihren Chef sprechen.
Das ist mir zu viel. Das ist das ja meine Güter, das gibt es ja nicht.
Jetzt komme ich extra in dieses Krankenhaus
und ich kann mir das nicht mehr verordnen.
Ich schreibe jetzt Ihren Namen auf.
Ja, natürlich. Mein Name ist Emitz.
Ich gehe zum Chefarzt.
Dann kann ich Ihnen das sagen.
Ja, wie ich gesagt habe, wir arbeiten als Team.
Ich werde Ihre Situation mit meinem Chef sprechen.
Nein, ich möchte jetzt Ihren Chef sprechen.
Ich möchte jetzt Ihren Chef sprechen.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ich gehe natürlich, wo alles sind.
Ich habe seit 2 Tagen mit dem Herzen kommen extra hierher
und Sie geben mir immer noch keine Schmerzmedikamente.
Ja, Herr Zauber, natürlich werde ich mit meinem Chef...
Nein, ich habe keine Geduld mehr. Bitte rufen Sie mir Ihren Chef.
Ja, ja, wie ich gesagt habe...
Der Chef ist doch der Herr Müller, oder?
Ja, Herr Müller, aber wie ich gesagt habe,
der soll sofort kommen. Der soll sofort kommen.
Das geht nicht. Das finde ich nicht in Ordnung.
Ja, okay, okay, Herr Zauber.
Das ist Unterlass in der Hilferleistung.
Das ist eine Unterlass in der Hilferleistung.
Ich möchte jetzt etwas gegen die Schmerzen haben.
Ja, okay, okay, Herr Zauber.
Bitte, rufen Sie mir Ihren Chef.
Ja, ja.
Der Chef hat gerade beschäftigt,
ich hänge eine Flüssigkeit bei Ihnen
und über Flüssigkeit eine Schmerzmittel geben.
Machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ja, bitte, bitte, darauf warte ich doch die Hande ganze Zeit.
Ja, okay.
Ein zumindest eine klare Infusion, dass die Schmerzen etwas nachlassen.
Sie können trotzdem Ihre Untersuchung machen.
Ich möchte Sie über Flüssigkeit geben.
Danke schön.
Sehen Sie, es wird schon besser.
Was haben Sie gegeben? Das hilft mir schon ganz gut.
Paristamol e-V.
Warum nicht gleich? Vielen Dank.
Ja, machen Sie sich keine Sorgen.
Ich mache mir so langsam Sorgen.
Danke schön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch andere Fragen?
Darf ich fragen?
Haben Sie Blut beim Stuhlgang bemerkt?
Ja, gute Frage, nein.
Danke schön.
Der Stuhlgang ist etwas heller, ist fast gelb.
Und der Stuhlgang ist sehr weich.
Okay.
Und weiter.
Haben Sie bemerkt, in nächster Zeit,
dass Sie Ihre Haut oder Augen merklich,
gelblich geworden sind?
Nicht so richtig, aber wo Sie das so sagen?
Ich glaube, heute Morgen, meine Augen waren etwas gelblich.
Ich glaube, da war ein feiner Unterschied zu sehen.
Das stimmt, wo Sie das so sagen.
Ich habe jetzt eigentlich kaum etwas gegessen.
Natürlich, wenn ich etwas versuche zu essen,
dann ist es schlimmer geworden.
Ich denke, alle Fragen sind gelblich.
Okay.
Kleine Pause oder gehen wir gleich weiter?
Umut.
Ich komme selber.
Wir müssen auf jeden Fall gebrauchen.
Ich denke, dass es wichtige Fragen nicht gestellt oder sehr spät sind.
Ich denke, bei der anderen Nese müssen wichtige Fragen gleich zu Beginn.
Und andere Fragen später.
Sie haben gesagt, dass es eine der Akademien ist.
Gegen diese Krankheiten haben Sie irgendein Medikament eingenommen?
Ja, das waren damals säure, lokiere Medikamente.
Das habe ich drei Wochen lang genommen.
Dann ist es besser geworden.
Haben Sie aufstoßen oder soll aufstoßen?
Damals, damals ja jetzt nicht.
Aber mit dieser Erkrankung habe ich wieder für März aufstoßen.
Viel Luft und Bauch.
Eine Frage.
Ist es in Deutschland, es ist wirklich, wenn die Patientin,
der Patient hat einen Bauchschmerz.
Kann der Arzt den Patienten Schmerzmittel geben oder muss bis zum Ende warten?
Ich glaube, das können wir am Ende besprechen.
Aber es kommt auf die Situation und auf die Schmerzen an natürlich.
Wenn es einigermaßen erträgliche Schmerzen sind und die Untersuchung nicht lange dauert.
Klar, dann möchten wir erst untersuchen.
Das ist klar.
Aber wenn sehr, sehr starke Schmerzen da sind, dann sollte man schon etwas geben.
Leiden Sie Herzklopfen oder Atemnot?
Nein.
Wir machen weiter oder?
Können wir weiter machen.
Herr Dietz?
Ja, Herr Oberast, heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Sehr schön.
Bitte schön.
Was ist das?
Erzähl mal.
Der Patient heißt Martin Zauwa.
Herr Zauwa ist 39 Jahre alt, 1,73 m und wiegt 85 kg.
Also einen jungen Mann, ja.
Er hat uns seit zwei Tagen bestehend durch den Kinderbau Schmerzen mit Strahlung in Rücken vorgestellt.
Laut dem Patienten, seine Schmerzintensität, die Liege, die Schmerzintensität, 7 bis 8 Pfonsen auf einer Schmerzskala
gegen Schmerz, habe er 2-mal überpropfen 400 mg und einmal Parastatomol 500 mg angenommen.
Aber es hat ihm nicht geholfen.
Der Patient klagte auch über MSI und einmal Gallies entschuldigen.
Der Patient klagte auch über, seit heute Morgen, nauseher und einmal Gallies MSI.
Und MSI ist nach dem Essen aufgetreten.
Okay.
Ich frage zu den Schmerzen, wie sind die Schmerzen und wohin strahlen sie nochmal aus?
Ja, die Schmerzen sind in Oberbau Schmerzen.
Epikastrat, rechte Oberbauch, linke Oberbauch, ist es gürtelförmig?
Ja, er hat erwähnt, dass die Schmerzen gürtephomik sei.
Okay.
Ja, und die Schmerzen strahlen in der Vulkan.
Ja, so, er hat...
Haben Sie ihm etwas gegen die Schmerzen gegeben?
Da muss er sicherlich sehr starke Schmerzen gehabt haben.
Entschuldigung?
Haben Sie ihm etwas gegen die Schmerzen gegeben?
Ja, ich habe ihm nichts gegeben.
Oh, das ist aber mutig.
Ja, nach der Umgebung.
Und der Patient hat sich nicht beschwert oder hat nichts gesagt?
Ja, er hat immer beschwert und ehrlich gesagt, konnte ich ihm nicht genau besprechen.
Und er hat immer beschwert und wollte mit ihnen sprechen.
Ah, okay.
Dann würde er mal nicht mit mir sprechen.
Warum haben Sie ihm keine Schmerzmedikamente gegeben?
Oder eine Infusion?
Ja, ihr habt gedacht, dass ich zuerst eine Diagnose feststellen muss.
Kann ich ein Medikament verordnen?
Okay.
Haben Sie keine Verdacht?
Haben Sie keine Verdacht, Diagnose?
Diagnose dauert ja manchmal lang.
Ja, natürlich habe ich einige Verordnungen, aber nach der Köpferle herunterzogen und Maßnahmen würde ich die Schmerzmedikate verordnen.
Gut, dann machen wir mal weiter.
Ja, und der Patient hat auch erwähnt, dass ihr Stuhl in der letzten Seite heller ist.
Sein Stuhl, das ist ein Herr, ne?
Sein Stuhl in der letzten Seite heller sein.
Ja, er hat auch berichtet, dass er im Augen Icterus bemerkt.
Haben Sie denn Icterus gesehen?
Haben Sie den Patienten über heute untersucht, was bemerkt?
Ja, ich habe nicht Icterus bemerkt, aber jetzt habe ich, wenn passiert, nicht untersucht.
Aber ja, ich werde Icterus bestätigen während der Untersuchung.
Aber Sie haben sich mit ihm unterhalten, da haben Sie doch seine Augen gesehen.
War die sehr stark geldlich oder war das noch relativ weiß?
Ja, ich glaube, da ich nicht bemerkt habe, wäre es…
Also kein richtiger Icterus?
Ja, so, ja, Teichkardi, Dispmy wurden von der Patient verneint.
Und ja, vor Erkrankungen leidet der Patient Angasritis und deswegen nehmen er Magischutstableten.
Er war 8 Jahre alt, wurde appendektomiert.
Er reagiert allergisch auf Polen und reagiert mit Epifoga.
Sein Icterus ist vollständig und die Reiseanämmnisse ist leer.
Vor 4 Jahren hat er aufgehört zu rauchen, aber zuvor Nikotinkonsum beträgt, einschacht er seit 25 Jahren, einschacht er täglich.
Er trinkt gelegenen Alkohol und er habe keine Erfahrungen mit Drogen.
Er fährt Fahrrad, aber nicht so oft gelegen.
Sein Vater leidet unter Diabetes-Meditus und Arterie-Hypertone und seine Mutter ist gesund.
Sie hat eine Schwester, die gesund sei.
Wer hat eine Schwester?
Erschlug.
Wer hat eine Schwester? Die Mutter?
Nein, der Patient hatte eine Schwester.
Die gesund sei.
Er hatte einen Partner, aber er hat vor einigen Wochen getrennt.
Zurzeit wohnt er allein und habe kein Kinder.
Er ist auch Bauengenieur.
Sie haben eine Ausführliche Anämmnese gemacht. Was ist Ihre Diagnose?
Ich habe eine Angabe von Deutschen Amnesten auf eine Koliolitis.
Ich habe einen Verdacht auf als differenzialen Diagnose folgende im Betrag.
Wir wollten eine Pancreatitis, eine Holistitis, eine Miovertiz.
Was machen Sie mit den Patienten? Welche Untersuchungen wollen Sie?
Werte wollen Sie haben?
Ja, um mein Verdachtdiagnost zu bestätigen und
differential Diagnost auszuschließen, würde ich
den Patienten zuerst körperlich untersuchen.
Ja, das ist klar.
Würde ich Blut abnehmen und
beim Blut würde ich
Leberwerte, ACT, ALT und
dann Blubin, GGT, ALT-Werte
überprüfen.
Oder auch
Entzündungsprimeter,
wie
Seripä, Prochalcitonin
überprüfen.
Um eine
Pankratitis auszuschließen
oder bestätigen, würde ich
Amylase und Lipaz-Werte überprüfen.
Okay, gut.
Weiter mit der ACT,
Was machen Sie da?
Natürlich, würde ich eine ACT schreiben
um die Ökotronfaktus auszuschließen.
Ja,
Blutabnahme,
werde ich
eine Abdominalzono-Grafik
durchführen.
Ja, okay.
Ja, dann gegebenenfalls,
und wenn ich eine Pankratitis bestätige,
würde ich
eine RCP und MRCP durchführen.
Gleich oder erst am nächsten Tag?
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob man
in Deutschland
RCP oder MRCP
in Notaufnahme durchführen kann, aber
Sie sind aufnimmende Arzt, Sie müssen das entscheiden.
Ja, in der Türkei haben wir manchmal
MRCP und
MRCP in Notaufnahme durchgeführt.
Ja, das ist aber eine gute Notaufnahme.
Situation in Deutschland.
Okay, haben die Kollegen noch Fragen,
weil ich habe mir einige Sachen hier aufnotiert.
Bei Bidiere Genese können wir MRCP durchführen.
Ja.
Nicht MRCP.
Okay, eine Endoskopie.
Ja.
Ja, in der Tür haben wir zuerst...
Entschuldigung,
sollen wir das Band noch laufen lassen
oder die Diskussion ohne die Aufnahme?
Okay, ein Moment.
Wie Sie wollen?
Nein.
Okay, machen wir die Aufnahme weiter?
Können wir weiter, weil dann
hören wir...
Weiterbespülen, okay.
Also, lieber Herr Doktor, ich habe mir jetzt
ein paar Sachen aufgeschrieben.
Die Verdachtdiagnose ist eigentlich
jetzt bei mir eine akute Pankreatitis gewesen.
Ja.
Warum?
Ganz klassisch, gürtelförmige Ausstrahlung
und der Stuhlgang ist hell.
Ja.
Bei einer Polycysteletiasis
ist es eigentlich den Oberbau
und das kann meistens kein gürtelförmiger
beschweren, kann, aber muss nicht.
Aber ich habe diesen Patienten seit einer Woche.
Wir sind jetzt Beispiele direkt aus der Praxis
und im Labor hat sich bestätigt,
er hat eine Lipase von über 3.000,
eine Amylase von 1.700,
ein Bili von 2,0,
eine Leberwerte, GOTGPDGAMMAGT,
waren ganz leicht erhöht, war nicht so.
CRP negativ,
keine Entzündungsparameter,
aber starke Schmerzen, Blähungen und so weiter.
Deswegen, ich hätte jetzt
als Differenzialdiagnose die Pankreatitis
als erstes, als Arbeitsdiagnose vermute.
Natürlich als Differenzialdiagnose
habe ich die Gallenblase und so weiter.
Aber wenn Sie jetzt gleich zu Beginn dieser Verdacht haben,
dann müssen Sie auch die richtigen Fragen gleich zu Beginn stellen, finde ich.
Zum Beispiel, Sie haben Ihre Diagnose
mit Polycysteletiasis oder Polycystitis,
aber Sie haben nicht gefragt den Patienten,
haben Sie bekanntes Gallenblasenstein
oder früher schon mal so eine Erkrankung gehabt,
haben Sie nicht gefragt. Dann haben Sie nicht gefragt,
nach der Übelkeit, die kamen ganz, ganz, ganz spät.
Ja, ich habe die Frage.
Ja, wir kamen ganz spät, wenn jemand mit Bauchschmerzen kommt,
dann ist die erste Frage, haben Sie Übelkeit erbrechen durchfallen.
Das kann auch eine ganz normale Gastritis
oder Gastroenteritis sein.
Ich denke, die Frage nach der Übelkeit muss viel früher kommen.
Der Patient hat gesagt, er hatte eine Gastritis gehabt,
und das fragt man dann.
Haben Sie eine Endoskopie gehabt?
Haben Sie eine Herdekobaxaphylorie gehabt?
Haben Sie eine Erradikationstherapie gehabt?
Diese Fragen haben Sie nicht gestellt.
Und wenn Sie an eine Pankreatitis denken, klar,
auch bei jungen Männern, Alkohol.
Dann müssen Sie ein bisschen nachragten.
Man fragt, trinken Sie Alkohol?
Dann sagt jeder, ja, so ein bisschen.
Nein, trinken Sie Wodka, trinken Sie Whisky.
Und wie viel Gläser trinken Sie am Tag?
Es ist morgens, mittags, abends.
Da müssen Sie etwas genauer nachragten.
Die Menschen sagen nicht gleich.
Auch die Alkoholiker sagen ja, ab und zu.
Aber wenn man nachfragt, dann kommt raus,
die trinken doch relativ viel.
Und der Mensch arbeitet auf einer Baustelle.
Und Sie müssen wissen, dass auf der Baustelle
sehr oft sehr viel Bier und Alkohol
während der Arbeit getrunken wird.
Da trinkt man, weil man draußen arbeitet.
Morgens, mittags, abends Bier wie Wasser.
Nur auf der Baustelle.
Und wenn man nach Hause kommt, am Abend trickt man nochmal 2 Flaschen Bier.
Also da muss man schon etwas genauer nachhaken.
Genau.
Und Sie haben als Differenzialdiagnose
Herzinfarkt erwähnt.
Aber es kam keine einzige Frage zu KHK
oder Herzinfarkt.
Sie haben nicht gefragt, oder es kam sehr spät mit der Dyspne.
Haben Sie schon mal Herzinfarkt gehabt?
Hat jemand in der Familie einen Herzinfarkt?
Wie lange haben Sie Luftnot?
Haben Sie bei Belastung Luftnot?
Alle Fragen zum Herzen sind leider,
oder viele Fragen, nicht gekommen.
Das waren so die Sachen, die mir aufgefallen sind.
Natürlich versucht man die Schmerzen
nicht zu überdeckern durch die Schmerztabletten,
dass man auch die richtige Diagnose stellt.
Aber wenn der Patient so, so starker Schmerzen hat,
wenn der Pankreatis ist,
ist eine der Erkrankungen, die sehr, sehr starker Schmerzen macht.
Man sollte schon ein bisschen wegen des Gebeschmerzmedikaments.
Zumindest mal Perfagatparzitamol oder Novalgien.
Dass es ein bisschen weniger wird.
Also ich finde, da müssen auch noch mal so den Punkt,
was viel ist, ist viel, was wenig ist, ist wenig.
Aber es müssen auch, glaube ich, die richtigen Fragen
als erstes gleichgestellt werden.
Das ist eine Frage, die ich mir auch noch einmal erinnert habe.
Ich habe mich auch noch einmal gefragt,
ob die richtigen Fragen als erstes gleichgestellt werden.
Das ist jetzt mein Eindruck.